قالت مساعده المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده فلورنسا سوتون نو ان
المنظمه الدوليه قلصت عملياتها الانسانيه
بمدينه دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه بشكل كبير
نتيجه للهجمات المتزايده في المنطقه بما
في ذلك الهجوم الذي اصاب مستودع الاونور
بشكل مباشر يوم الخميس الماضي واكدت سوتو
نينو ان الهجوم تسبب في مقتل احد موظفي
الامم
المتحده قلصت العمليات الانسانيه في دير
البلح بشكل كبير نتيجه للهجمات المتزايده
بما في ذلك الهجوم الذي اصاب بشكل مباشر
مستودع الاونروا يوم الخميس ما ادى الى
مقتل احد موظفي الامم المتحده وتقع
المستودعات ومراكز التوزيع والمراكز
الصحيه والملاجئ ضمن المناطق التي صدرت
لها اوامر الاخلاء حديثا واطر العديد من
المخابز التي تدعمها الامم المتحده
وشركائها الى اغلاق عملياتها في دير البلح
نتيجه القتال